sweeps it off on the T mckin rammed ahead
for Jonathan drw try to put it down the
board comes back to mckinon try to Dish it
across Ranson turns it fires it's blocked
Away by makoy and really just structur to
detail plays a simple game he's played 20
games in the American Hockey League turnover
save by Gori of oh man you cannot give David
poog that kind of opportunity finds drwan you
look at third in the NHL are the bees on the
kill back down for drwan cross eyes m one timer
save by Swan and couldn't land it flat in time
for ranton who was ready to just bounce on it
almost to turnover now it is co is in save by
goria oh boy Coy Racing for the loose Puck and
it's picked up by Tes here com the ERS now to
chusa gives it off for drw that's cing passage
for mckinon they'll turn it back the other way
for deuss to to the avalance own down deep shoots
and a save by goria again unbelievable by the way
I'm a Gala person you're Gala I've been brawling
over this for a couple days actually Marsh snaps
it scores bra marshan came into the top of the
circle on let in RI and the bullets have a one-
nothing lead for Marette that's his 16th goal
of the Season at 35 years of age Brad marshan
almost a point per game still and the Bruins
come in just keep it simple you can see Zach
is in front screening that's the key 18 for the
Bruins is the key as soon as Marshon sees that
then he's just going to try and find some net
it's a perfect goalie screen just like auskin
screens for the ABS Maron picks that corner with a
nice screen by Pabo zaka in front no by way to it
fou sweeps it up for K fired for TR here's M get
it down low stop four m r it down to one KNE the
perfect redirect Tom Shell and the ABS have tied
the game at one for R and in his 21st goal of the
Season his point streak and hold continues M just
puts down the paddle if it doesn't go off a stick
he'll hit his [__] bad hit Escape but here he
gets all stick look at how far down he puts his
hands over halfway down on this stick McKinnon
knows it sees it sweet little pass between the
legs and moik just buries that with all the
heart and soul he's got great overhead look
Scoops that oh that was barred down into the
back of the net what a beautiful go nice flip
down the boards from makoy what you said that one
is milinski and a nice play up the board that one
will crawl all the way to the neutal zone L tried
to take it away log C with the steel walks and
scores Logan Oh Conor and shot Kirk and the Bruins
Twisted Inside Out makes the steel comes in and he
rips it past the glub hand of Swingman the ABS
for Logan o' Conor his sixth of the season and
right now he's right off you want to talk about
everything this is what it's all about for Logan o
Conor he buries his sixth of the season just stays
with it confuses the Bruins as they po into one
another and then he comes in and goes absolute
shell and when Logan o Conor gets on he scores
some absolute highlight real goals the Bruins with
such a good PK third in the NHL ads have already
solved them once blood timer save by Swingman
that's that pressure you were talking about
rker bruss went out to meet Mard ran it speeds
it off Swift around by shoot Get Buckets loose
oh we talk about the prese Scout and that's
exactly what Boston knows McKinnon loves the
onetime carler got Lan Frederick P off shoots save
rebound over skated by cor oh the ab CAU a shoes
break redirect hit a body as right now caught a
little bit they've had some guys out there for a
while up to the point it goes Carlo walks shoves
it down deep AB he surviv this right now wrap
around try save rebound still and it's beer short
side Alexander gorgia breaks his stick on the post
and the Bruins have tied the game into lots of
time to recover from that but right here at that
moment Moi said they just have to survive this
the Bruins were storming and beer jumps in scores
his fifth goal of the Season just his 36th career
NHL game you talked about him being just young 22
years old that's the fourth line for the Bruins
they're so excited car up top for Taves this is
ranid it Tes one timer save rebound shot oh
it's up a body over the top of the net Hil M
trailing Quint Hughes for the scoring lead for
defenseman of the National Hockey League he's
played fewer games however malinsky with a shot
he scores Sam molinsky walked and fired wasn't
deflected the ABS have a 32 lead malitsky
letting it go second goal of his National
Hockey League career and the young defenseman
just let it try and who does that look like on
the point almost had to do a double check now
the comparisons to kale Mar would not be fair
but to stop up like he did and get that r on
that is exactly how K mcart doesn't saminski
have to paid extra special attention to 88 tonight
he's so Dynamic turnover Kim walks in shoots safe
rebound oh he could get the Second Chance tried to
filter it far aside from McKinnon who was just off
the bench on the stick of geeki a dangle move
and a save by gorgi what a move by geeki turn
around Maran wi than Ed hasn't been winning the
shot attempt category the Brews now picking it up
and there strict orders from Jim Montgomery I'm
sure in front score a back door play Brad Maran
with his second of the game has made it 33 he just
crept into the far side and an excellent pass o
[__] and here's the goal watch this behind the
back pass right there a that's remarkable McKinnon
sees the Pocky is in good position he just
couldn't knock it down oh I see it got knuckled
and he could hit T's skate on the way over to go
to Center for that by off to the balance got back
up hit the post T heing rins it off the iron
zaka is ah head to geeki givs it up PS it up
down deep save goria loose Pucket it's kick to
the corner picked up by nukin everybody thought
it was down low fou Dres it ahead he's got Jack
Johnson with him nin to Johnson oh what a save by
San he'll seek ref huge back behind the
cage here comes the breakout kale M flying
down the wing K Mar to the Brewing Zone in
front through it through it off the leg of
San the left P was out there and he holds
on Gil Mar here's the pass the watch it
he gets it there yeah there's no hook of
any kind and then nebras yard sails into
the back wall right there he's got to grab
it try and go upstairs and just couldn't
find the Rhythm to make it happen as he's
moving at 20 mph looks easy from up here
here he'll pick it up at Cent I post slow
down the slot but he watches tape so here
he comes in tries to sneak it five can win it
for the ABS his first shoot out of the Season
Here Comes Val works it in thein slow toward
the front of the hold Sho scores B toin the
shootout goal and the ABS beat the Boston bro
by a final score of 4 to3 he beats swayan Val
comes in goes real slow he's just looking to
pick a spot five hole far left side top corner
and he slides it over the pad and under the
glove head up the whole way he sees his shot
he executes and then here comes the best
celebration in hockey when he brings the
right hand up to say yeah baby that's your game
winner what a hockey game tonight in Paul Arena